I'll talk to to to Rogan about this a
little bit because you know I'll let him
not be like man the shitty thing the
annoying thing about getting money is uh
there's less to complain about like when
I didn't have money I was like affected
by every issue I was like oh we gotta
talk we gotta fix this and change and
then I got some money and I was like man
like the Ahmad Geary is a great place to
hang out for a weekend it's like do I
really want to read this whole article
about abortion or do I want to go to
Utah and look at mountains yeah that's
way better you know and then Rogan was
like when you have kids it just brings
you right back in I go why he goes he
goes because now everything is affecting
the way they see the world and your kid
is going to say something to you and
it's going to [ __ ] rile you up I got
a friend of mine who lives up in Toronto
and his kid he got two kids and he and
he was giving cookies he gave two
cookies to his baby girl and then one
cookie to his son and his son goes uh
his son goes uh he goes he goes hey I
want two cookies and he goes why he goes
because fair and equal